L RAFAEL REIF: Good morning.
Look, it's a little cold and wet
out there, so let's warm
ourselves up.
Good morning!
AUDIENCE: Good morning.
L RAFAEL REIF: That's better.
To the graduates of 2013,
congratulations.
One more time you'll hear it,
and you deserve to hear it
several times today.
I know I'm the last thing
standing between you and your
diplomas, so even though I have
a great deal I want to
tell you, I will be brief.
To everyone who has come here
this morning to celebrate the
graduates of 2013,
welcome to MIT.
And to the parents and families
of today's graduates,
congratulations to
you, as well.
It's great.
It's great to have you all here
in Killian Court for this
tremendously important
occasion.
Now the last time that I was out
here with a big group of
people, we were having a
huge snowball fight.
I know that many members
of the class of 2013
were part of it.
To those of you who got
me wet, consider this
weather as round two.
And I personally invite you to
come back next winter for a
healthy rematch.
I'm told that before we let you
graduate, I'm expected to
give our graduating
class a charge.
That sounds to me like one last
problem set, one last
PSET, MIT is giving
you, all of you.
That is quite a fun challenge.
I'm also told not to worry too
much about what I'm telling
you, as you're likely to forget
whatever I say two
seconds after I'm done.
So that is yet another
fun challenge I'm
eager to take on.
Let me start by welcoming you
again to the MIT family, even
though you joined our family the
moment you registered as
an MIT student for the
very first time.
And this is no ordinary
family.
First of all, the MIT
family is big.
Its core members include MIT's
127,000 alumni world-wide,
including those over there
looking spiffy in their
colorful red jackets.
Spiffy and wet, I might add.
Our MIT family also includes the
remarkable members, past
and present, of the MIT faculty,
as well as our
students, post-docs,
and staff.
Now, as you all know,
this is not a family
you are born into.
You have to earn being a
member of our family.
And our big family opens its
arms to all of those who are
committed and dedicated
to MIT's mission,
principles, and values.
This family you chose to join
years ago has been busy.
Over the years, members of the
MIT family have been awarded
the Nobel Prize 78 times.
That is over 9% of all Nobel
Prizes ever awarded.
There are only three countries
with more Nobel Prizes than
the MIT family--
the US, the UK, and Germany.
Also at last count, living MIT
alumni have founded about
26,000 active companies.
Do the math.
That's one company for every
five living graduates.
Those companies provide jobs
for 3.3 million people, and
they produce $2 trillion
in global revenues.
And that was before Dropbox.
I don't have to tell you
that our big family
likes to do big things.
This family is ambitious--
incredibly, beautifully,
disruptively, ambitious.
There is simply no
place like MIT.
Our great family embraces many
styles and personalities.
I have met many of you, the
graduates of 2013, in
the last few years.
When I ask you, what
is it that you like
the most about MIT?
you have answered, each other.
You have also told me that you
did not know until you got to
MIT that smartness comes in
so many different ways.
So you know MIT, and you know
each other very well.
And you know that we all share
some deep values--
a commitment to excellence,
integrity, meritocracy, an
open spirit of collaboration,
a strong desire to make a
positive impact, and a sense of
responsibility to make the
world a better place.
In fact, Mr. Sal Khan, one
of our very accomplished
graduates and last year's
commencement speaker, came
back here to visit
this spring.
And he explained that he can
always spot someone from MIT,
even without checking for a
brass rat, because, he said,
when you tell them that some
problem is impossible, their
eyes light up.
That is you.
That is MIT.
The MIT family is famous
for all these things--
world famous.
As you go out into the world,
you may find that these family
characteristics set you apart.
They will make you different,
and I believe they will serve
you very well.
As you leave us today, however,
I want you to
appreciate another
side of MIT, too.
It came into focus for me this
year like never before.
I began to notice it last fall,
when a student named
Lydia K. published a blog
that captured the
attention of the campus.
She described an intense
period of sadness and
self-doubt.
And hundreds of MIT students
reached out to her in support.
I saw this side of MIT after
the Boston Marathon attack.
I received letters from total
strangers who had fled the
bombing site, and stumbled
into our fraternities and
sororities in Boston.
And they felt compelled to write
because they were so
moved by our students'
generosity and kindness.
I also saw this other aspect
of MIT in the great wave of
support and sympathy across our
community for every one
affected by the Boston
Marathon attack.
Then a few days later, the
tragedy of the marathon
bombing arrived at
our own campus.
And the whole world
saw what I saw--
the extraordinary outpouring of
respect and gratitude for
our beloved MIT police.
And the loving sympathy that
flowed from the heart of this
family to the family
of Officer Collier.
I've never felt so proud
to be part of MIT.
Today, I can tell you for
certain that the world will
respect you for what you
know, and for what
you know how to do.
But I also want the family of
MIT to be famous for how we
treat people--
famous for sympathy,
humility, decency,
respect, and kindness.
I'm certain that no matter what
I say, you will take on
important problems.
I'm certain that each of you
will, in your own way, honor
the great privilege we all
share in being here.
And I'm certain you will use
what you have learned - in
your labs and classrooms, in
your living rooms, on the
playing fields, in your
activities, and in late night
conversations with friends - I'm
certain you will use what
you've learned here to make
the world a better place.
Yet, I want to charge you to
do something else, too.
And this is your last PSET.
As you go out into society,
I want you to
change the source code.
I want you to rewire the
circuits, rearrange the
molecules, reformulate
the equation.
In short, I want you to hack the
world until you make the
world a little more like MIT.
[APPLAUSE]
L RAFAEL REIF: More daring
and more passionate, more
rigorous, inventive and
ambitious, more humble, more
respectful, more generous,
and more kind.
If Sal Khan were here, he would
advise me to tell you
that this is impossible.
On this wonderful day, I'm proud
of all of you, as I know
you are ready.
So now, go out there, join the
world, find your calling,
solve the unsolvable,
shape the future,
take the high road.
And you will continue to make
your family, including your
MIT family, proud.
To the graduating class of
2013, my first class,
congratulations.
[APPLAUSE]